spider-man fan right here and that has
got to be the best unscreened spider-man
and Peter Parker I have seen to date
seriously Tom Holland great job he's
named the movie for very long but now
I'm interested to see where they go with
him because he was excellent
Captain America's Civil War so Captain
America's Civil War is the third Captain
America movie the second Captain America
movie directed by the Russo brothers
they also directed Captain America
Winter Soldier and in this movie
tensions are rising governments and
countries out there start thinking of
themselves like maybe these Avengers
need to be contained reigned in
controlled and from there comes a divide
there are two sides to that opinion our
pros and cons here pros and cons there
Tony Stark picks one side he's like yeah
we should be contained we should be
controlled we should be made official
Captain America slide is like once the
control starts where does it stop and he
actually raises a few other points I
don't want to spoil for you point is
they have two completely different
ideologies on that subject so now the
Avengers crew they all have to choose
which side they're on
thus a civil war you have to keep one
thing in mind in this movie there are a
couple of different movies in this movie
you have a sequel to Captain America
Winter Soldier and you have a sequel to
The Avengers the Civil War part is a
sequel to the Avengers but this movie is
first and foremost a sequel to Captain
America Winter Soldier in that Captain
America Steve Rogers and his friend
Bucky Barnes who is the Winter Soldier
they are in the forefront their
friendship is what matters here most all
the Civil War stuff that happens is
great but it is a byproduct of that
relationship and I didn't feel obligated
to warn you about that I need to brace
you for that because all the Civil War
stuff was really cool but really it's a
lot of tension that builds throughout
the movie the Civil War stuff comes
later that's what the Russos do so well
it'd be just so easy to have everyone
suit up early on everyone just flies
fights fights fights flies than the
movies over but no they builds character
they build tension they build depth they
build tone they build layers and as the
tension on this Civil War dilemma is
building throughout the movie it's great
because you do see both sides of it I
was team cap when I read the comic books
and I was going into this movie going
alright I'm team cap but you do see both
sides in this movie that's what this
movie does well and that's what's
interesting in a conflict in a movie
where there are two sides you want the
movie to portray to you the two sides of
the argument that make you go I do see
both sides that just makes it more
interesting that makes you feel as stuck
as the characters in the movie at
appointing this movie I was like this is
the most important decision any of them
are going to make ever don't know about
that because really bad shits coming but
so far this is the biggest thing they've
ever had to decide on and I can say this
if you do not flip-flop at all in this
movie you're up
on which side you stand on you were just
being unbearably stubborn you're being a
robot Black Panther gets a lot of shine
too I like that I really cuz I going it
I don't know much about Black Panther
I'm gonna be honest with you guys but
this is my strong introduction to that
character and I really liked him he
worked for this story and situation in
ways I can't really touch on here in my
spoiler free review the action in this
movie was great also there were a couple
of parts where it got a little shaky in
scenes and not even not just shaky but
there something's going down and they're
like four cuts where you like that's
kind of jarring but it didn't compromise
the whole of the experience it is a
gripe on my part though but completely
forgiving that because this movie has
the greatest all-star Royal Rumble
comic-book hero Throwdown ever I've ever
seen on screen you've seen the trailer
you've seen the clash coming yeah all
those personalities all those
superpowers all of it is on screen for
you and it is insanely entertaining and
I really stress personality because
their personalities are coming through
while their superpowers are throwing
down it's exciting it's entertaining
it's funny there's humor in the
throwdown that fight hits all the notes
it needed to hit and a few more I didn't
even think for it to hit
and if we're touching on the biggest
gripe in this movie the villain is just
a useless weasel I don't even know if
he's a villain villain
funny thing I walked out of this movie I
spent the entire day going it was really
cool that this movie was like the first
Marvel movie word there wasn't a villain
villain the antagonist was the opposite
side of the side you wanted to be on
each side was an antagonist and each
side was also a hero that was really
cool then I was like oh god I totally
forgot about that one dude that was like
doing hehehe I'm gonna show them [ __ ]
who is he what is he why is he I mean we
find out all of that in the movie of
course one is I just don't think he
needed to be in this movie I feel like
you could really watch this movie in any
direction he takes the characters the
characters would have reached on their
own through a different path in
different means but in the end he didn't
really provide anything new that they
had to deal with that they wouldn't have
found on their own if he wasn't in the
movie at all if he just got edited out
you'd be down one action scene guys in
the end the Russo brothers for the
second time now in a Captain America
movie have shown us that you can take
comic-book action fun and mix it with
interesting characters and deep personal
motivation it's really important in the
comic book movie world now because comic
book movies are huge and they gotta know
that they can't just be comic book eye
candy that just happens all the time
that's fun and all and I have a fun time
with it personally but if that's all we
get that's gonna be fleeting and we're
all gonna get bored as some people are
already getting bored I say already like
it hasn't been eight years now I'm loves
the Captain America Civil War like
Captain America Winter Soldier before it
shows us that these movies can have
layers to them I find myself in a no-win
situation if I get this movie's awesome
tacular I'm accused of sucking Marvel's
dick what to do I give a [ __ ] that's
what because Captain America Civil War
is kick-ass and Captain America Civil
War is awesome tacular do what I love
about what Captain America Winter
Soldier did and what Civil War continues
to do is put its heroes under the
microscope it makes them fallible it
shows that when these people of power
conflict these heroes collide people get
hurt and people die if you can think
back to the other Marvel movies where
you look at it you're like people
clearly died in that situation they had
to have but it's never really touched on
and in Captain America's Civil War it is
touched on it's like no we have to
really humor the possibility that we're
not actually doing better we're not
doing good for the people because people
are just dying because of us it's a
really ballsy move it is gutsy and I
give them props for that funny thing a
lot of people haven't seen this movie
yet so me asking you have you seen it
what did you think about it isn't really
relevant till three weeks down the road
so from what you know of the conflicts
so far team Iron Man or team cap I'll
tell you what team I'm leaning on when I
do my spoiler video because that's when
I could really dig deeper into it that's
for you whatever side you're on whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more